if your goal is just views and
subscribers and that means helping to
you shorts is probably the fastest way
to go off and do it if you are hoping to
sell your coaching or your products or
your services or you're hoping that
people end up watching your long form
video
it seems completely disconnected that's
the best part of Brandon is good to
bring it right to you of what's
Happening behind the scenes
there was a question in our Facebook
group about shorts and whether putting
shorts on your channel leads to people
then consuming the long form version of
the video
to date that has not been my experience
it's its own algorithm shorts is all
over the map in terms of what people are
doing
um some people are saying this tank in
their Channel some people are saying
it's really helping their Channel here's
the my current you know October 2022
take on shorts uh that might help so one
it can be a great way to be able to get
views and even subscribers for the
channel
it's easier to get exposure on shorts
than uh than anything else it's easy to
get exposure on a short than a long form
video right now uh YouTube does uh same
with Tick Tock there's a lot of work
like promoting new people as well so you
can stand out and get
a lot more views and subscribers if that
was your goal uh and this is by the way
something that there's a lot of
discussions behind the scenes with a lot
of my friends and people with like brand
name people that you know with millions
of subscribers they're still trying to
figure out and they're asking me what do
I do with shorts so that's that's the
best part of Brandon it's good to bring
it right to you of what's Happening
behind the scenes so if your goal is
just views and subscribers and that
means something to you shorts is
probably the fastest way to go off and
do it you know like if you if you want
that 100K uh silver plaque if you want
the gold you know plaque that's probably
the fastest way to do it
but a lot of that is not converting to
anything
so if you if you are hoping to sell your
coaching or your products or your
services or you're hoping that people uh
end up watching your long-form video it
seems completely disconnected
so people don't watch a short at least
from all the data that I've seen and
then go and watch the long form version
of that video it's its own algorithm
uh and people who are watching you know
short content don't necessarily want to
go watch an hour long video or 10 minute
long video they're they're just swiping
through the feed
so it can help uh it can help grow the
channel but it doesn't help get views on
your long form videos at least yet
so why should you do it or why shouldn't
you do it YouTube is putting a lot more
effort into shorts they're monetizing
shorts they came out and said next year
they're going to be monetizing shorts
meaning you get to make money off of
your shorts how much it is we'll see
they set the split but uh who knows how
much money is actually going to be
coming in
it's a big step up though compared to
tick tock and Instagram reels where
people are posting content and they're
not making any money so YouTube has
always been the best monetization path
like direct monetization considering how
much effort and energy they're putting
into it I would say it's good to have a
short strategy
so I would gear people towards creating
some content on shorts my my uh what
we're doing is we do two long form
pieces of content a day and one short a
day that's kind of crazy what I would
suggest is on days where you're not
doing long form content
to experiment with shorts
some people are saying uh that shorts
killed my channel and
I would break that up into two different
paths one at the very beginning when
shorts is coming out it was messing up a
lot of people's channels uh you they
changed how they show shorts and so it
hasn't been as big of an issue except
when you look at the traffic sources on
shorts you have to see where it's coming
from so I was just looking at a channel
uh on Monday and
it's got what over 7 million subscribers
on this channel it's like shorts is
killing my channel when you go and you
look at the traffic sources on shorts
you can see it's coming from search
which search actually doesn't drive a
ton of views to shorts so like what is
going on why is the number one traffic
Source always search because they were
going to YouTube and they were typing
the Channel's name
and then the shorts would show up
so that actually hurts the channel
right if I'm going to go and type in
Terry Thompson
and then the short shows up instead of a
long form piece of content which one
would we much rather show up we'd want
the long form right so now instead of
people watching his long form content
they're watching his shorts so it's
getting tons of views but it's not
um when it's coming from search it's
actually hurting the growth of where he
wants to go with the channel and killing
the revenue on his channel so the key
thing to look at if you're doing shorts
is look at the traffic sources so for
every video it'll show you what the
traffic sources is as long as the number
one traffic source is the shorts tab
then you're good
if browse is number one that's not good
if uh search is number one that's not
good I've never seen suggested be number
one but if suggested is number one
that's not good either
because we if you think about browse
that means it's showing up on the home
page we'd much rather have people visit
your long form videos than your shorts
it'll just lead to better conversions
for everything in your business and more
monetization uh if you and same thing
for for YouTube search so
I it's an area to play in right now it's
like it's a skill set to get good at
because knowing how to make short form
content allows you to win on Tick Tock
and Instagram reels and YouTube shorts
and all the other platforms because
they're short form
um but I'm I still wouldn't recommend
going all in on it uh because it there's
no
great practical business case at least
inside thought leadership and
Entrepreneurship and education right now
so that's my quick little take on shorts
where we're at right now uh we'll see
when monetization comes out early next
year uh how things might change and as
I'm testing I mean I have a dedicated
shorts Channel we're up uploading
four to five shorts every day
and I'm doing it on my main Channel not
to really grow the channel just as an
experiment because I kind of need to
know this stuff so I can help others
with it too
let's go brand Linux keys to getting
suggested one of my favorite topics of
all time for YouTube suggested is the
number one way to grow your channel in
thought leadership suggests is where you
want to go because
just setting the framework because you
want your content to live forever search
is only 30 of entire YouTube and browse
is way too Hit or Miss way too trendy to
be able to win consistently on so inside
of thought leadership suggest it is
where you want to play your content
lives forever but before that happens
you have to rank against yourself so
Step One is how do I get suggested
against myself
and this is where at the beginning
stages of a channel can feel slow growth
because you're not getting picked up
against big channels ultimately your big
growth comes from being suggested
against big channels against huge videos
so you want to be suggested against my
videos against Tony Robbins videos
against Brandon Richard videos or inside
your Niche that's what your big growth
comes but that doesn't happen until you
get suggested against your own videos
first
and just think about in YouTube's
perspective why would they show you
against some big video If you're not
even showing up against yourself if
you're not even for your own audience
converting people over to want to watch
they're not going to show you against a
big video so whatever what ends up
happening is
um your your you see the slow go slow go
slow growth and then one suggests it
becomes your number one traffic Source
oftentimes you see an explosion of
growth for the channels because it means
you're suggested against your own then
you're suggesting to sellers so let's
show how to do it and this for this
video I'm going to uh break down my own
channel my top 10 Channel
and kind of take you guys a little
behind the scenes of what we're doing
and the advice I would give myself that
I can go give my team as well to go
execute so if I look at the breakdown
for my top 10 Channel suggested
is number one so 22 uh Channel pages is
number two because we promoted off my
main page then browse and search and
everything else right so the search is
nine percent
it's not huge and and it shouldn't be
huge and if your goal is to get people
to subscribe to your channel right if
you have some utility Channel where you
don't care about subscriptions then
search can be great but if we care about
people coming back and watching content
consistently suggestions where you need
to be so this is where we get massive
growth so how do you show up against
your own videos how do you get suggested
against your own channel
here's what you need to do a couple
things one consistent design
so if you look at my channel you look at
my videos there's always that consistent
design you know what an Evan Chronicle
thumbnail looks like
right and on this channel
we use white uh whatever blue we want to
call that and then still the logo
right and so whether these are the new
videos that just came out this is these
are the videos that are the most popular
so some of these are a year ago
whether it's you know something that
came out yesterday or something came out
a year ago it's still the same kind of
style the only one that's different is
this one which isn't that different this
is where we were testing having the text
all being in a block
so it's just one big Square where
everything else we found this actually
performs better where it's not all
chunked right so you have different
lengths of the lines it's easier to read
um but besides that that's a pretty
minor change I look at that it's like oh
that one's really different but for most
people looking at it they're like okay
this is this is a different comical
thumbnail so I need to know what does
your thumbnail style look like because
to show up suggested against our own and
I know we've talked about this in the
past when they've clicked on if I click
on this Brandon burchard video here and
I like it like I like this channel I'm
going to look down the side and see what
else is there and if I can't recognize
your thumbnail because it's a totally
different style then I'm not going to
click on it so you're losing views on
your own videos
so it doesn't have to be exactly the
same that is a mistake so not exactly
the same not the exact same LinkedIn
profile picture it's what a lot of
people will do exact same picture they
have one good picture of them
and then that's the picture on every
single thumbnail don't do that right uh
you'll see none of these are actually
the fancy pictures they're screenshots
from within the video every single one
of these is a screenshot within the
video
uh similar text similar font similar
logo placement
it's okay to test in The Tweak in the
play but then the best thing you can do
is go back on your older videos when you
found the winning design and go test
those and improve them so that if I if
you go look at this channel
content as far as a year ago is all
going to be similar
so it encourages people to want to click
if they like it they want to click
second end card strategy I've tweaked
this up in the past when did we do this
three months ago two months ago
uh one big end card at the end linking
to the most relevant video not a
playlist
so if you look at my stuff six months
ago you would have seen an end card with
playlist playlist
uh subscribe and a link to my website to
get a lead magnet
and we look at all the numbers uh and
this is actually outperforming all of
those combined
so this one end card at the end click
into a single video is outperforming the
four elements I used to have combined
so this is now what I'm doing on all my
channels is what I'm telling all the big
guys to do as well
at the end of every video you have 20
seconds to put with on the end card you
you point to the video so first you have
to pick the video right so this is a
video on Kevin O'Leary we're linking to
another Kevin O'Leary video the most
relevant related video to the one that
you just made that's already on your
Channel
and you could pitch it for 20 seconds or
you could talk about it for 10 seconds
have highlights from that video for 10
seconds you look to it you point to it
even at the end now I'm saying and I'll
see you there like that's at the end
both fingers the video right there next
to me I think you'll love it continues
to believe and I'll see you there
go watch that video Yeah Mark's got it
um there's arrows that fly in you know
big video right here in the middle hand
selected that that we think is going to
be the best one for them not YouTube's
most relevant uh or best review or not
YouTube's most recent you pick it uh and
again what we're doing is we're training
people that once they watch one video
they're watching another they're
watching another they're watching
another YouTube's gonna recommend your
videos a lot more to people so this has
had a uh a big impact on getting more
sessions more views in on the session
which then leads to more suggested views
as well
and then playlist in the newsletter if
any of you guys have newsletters
even if it's 500 people or you're
sharing to social media you have to put
the playlist in the newsletter so I've
talked about this before I can dive in
again if you guys want of how to do this
but basically if I look at this video
here so this is I don't think I've
shared this before where I share with
the news this is the newsletter
Drew is saying this is a must I'll cast
it's a huge deal so this is the actual
newsletter it's super short there's
there's basically nothing here right
this is the video that I'm trying to
promote and it's it's a picture Jamie uh
this is the video you know why did why
did Jamie get fired for talking too much
how did she how did she I even made a
typo how did she got from witness to
billionaire
find out my recent video on her right
uh this is a link this is a link this is
a link and the picture that bonds a link
so there's four different links to the
video in here I experienced with a whole
bunch of different versions of this
where I'd have a lot more details I'd
show what the rules are I'd share the
highlights from it give a lot more
explanation it didn't lead to as many
clicks this leads to the most number of
clicks so super basic simple easy for
people to land on the video
Drew says I 3x the channel Revenue with
this one strategy
it's a big deal so then when they click
on the video they get to the video but
the key to that strategy is it shows
in the side my playlist so there's 445
videos here on this channel that are
public
so after this one they'll watch another
one and another one another one if they
if they leave it open some people may
close it that's fine but it auto leads
them to watch the next video on the
channel
and you can do a custom playlist if you
want most people find that too much work
I just do the uploads playlist and if
you guys need help in how to actually
find that link
I can uh we can do that at the end as
well during q a time but it's a big deal
so this is a little hard to see if I
zoom in on it you can see that there's
there's the video link and then at the
end it says and list equals so this adds
that playlist at the end so you still
get the same video The Experience from
the user is the same they're watching
the video I click for a video I get the
video but what happens after the video
ends is going to send me down this
Rabbit Hole of all my other videos
almost nobody's doing it and if you have
a newsletter list or you're sharing a
social again if you're sharing the one
person doesn't make a difference but if
you're sharing to a group of people
that has the potential for lots of
people to click on it that can make a
big impact for you playlists can be uh
scary for people
playlist can be scary they don't want to
stand up and commit to watching 40
minutes or or whatever playlists can be
scary so it's one video and when I click
it again I get to the video so from a
user experience perspective I'm actually
still just getting that one video it's
just what happens at the end
what happens at the end is they'll go to
the next video automatically instead of
just a video ending
and what some people will do is they
will just have it open
in the tab they'll mute the video and
have it open in a tab
and then it just runs and they forgot
that they had this open in the tab
and eight hours later your videos are
still playing that counts for a lot of
watch time and then you get a lot more
suggested
we talked about going longer and this is
a relatively new thing uh if you go back
two years on YouTube even a year on
YouTube it wasn't as big a deal as it is
now inside of thought leadership and
it's super weird because
almost everybody else is going shorter
YouTube Shorts YouTube stories Instagram
reels Tick Tock everybody's going
shorter
in thought leadership it's like don't
even worry about shorts I haven't seen
anybody win with shorts we have two
shorts channels I haven't proven that
that that it is worth your time or
investment I'm telling everybody to go
long go long long longer longer
10 minute minimum but go half an hour go
an hour go three hours if you're good
like if you know what you're talking
about if you can give a master class it
has a much better chance of helping you
build the channel and build a business
that you want as opposed to the really
short videos uh so just to refresh your
back to the top
the hashtag YouTube Longs says true uh
Eddie posted this video this was his
challenge that we had after the last
month post a three-hour video and he did
and because he posted to the group and
guys share yourself in a group share
your win share what you need help with
because you might get featured on a
future for analytics session you never
know
let's look at this video so I uh I was
on I as soon as Eddie posted this and
like ooh let's see how it's doing let's
see how we're doing Eddie I want this
video to win is Evan Karma go right or
not
doesn't work because Eddie's also kind
of On The Fringe of thought leadership
right it's not just a talking head or
coaching videos it's on the motivation
side
so
views are down
right this is this is uh days so this
video is nine days old and Views are
down and this is where people freak out
you know they look at their one their
two days like oh my God this video sucks
like it's half of what my usual The Gray
Line represents the usual this is what
an average video would do and the blue
line represents this specific video
uh so it's down but look hey it's
catching up it's catching up to our
average already this is actually pretty
fast
I would I would say even within a month
suggested to get suggested to grow is
fast
I would be expecting typically in like
the 30 to 90 days where it starts to
take off and then over 90 days for sure
but if you're getting it to start to
catch up inside of the first two weeks
you're doing a really good job so
overall views are down okay
watch time oh that's some nice watch
time look at that watch time that is a
delicious looking curve right that's
this video and this is his average so
he's already double his average watch
time in the first nine days
all right so amazing amazing start
let's look at why
so these two curves represent suggested
is the blue line and browse is the green
line and I looked at it yesterday and
browse was still at the top just barely
but today
gotta check back in this morning to get
the most recent day that suggested is at
the top so you see browse is going it's
good it's decent and it's still climbing
but it's this is what happens with
browse like it takes off at the
beginning and then it just slowly keeps
going hopefully and maybe you'll get a
pop every now and then because you hit
the home page but suggest that this
curve can keep going forever
so already inside of nine days suggests
it has passed his brows
which is great
you look at the average view duration
and these numbers may be a little hard
to see but uh I'll just read it out loud
suggested 33 minutes
browse 16 minutes
because how long people are watching
so in browse you're only watching for 16
minutes which is still great that's
still a good number
but they're watching for 33 minutes when
they come from suggested it's double
and that's why it's starting to take off
and you'll see that people on the home
page will have a much shorter attention
span this this should go this should be
repeated if you look at your own
everybody here you look at your own
channel stats look at the average view
duration browse versus suggested
it would shock me if brows was higher
suggested is is always number one
so that's where we're gonna go because
YouTube cares about watch time so we're
giving them lots and lots and lots of
watch time here
so even though the views are half
like the views are 1500 versus 3000 the
watch time is already more
we're getting more watch hours from
suggested with half the views
this is a great video
uh I took a screenshot yesterday last
night this is this one and I took a
screenshot again this morning this is
this one you can see it's already it's
picking up it's already doing better and
look at the number one traffic Source
last night suggested was 42 this morning
suggested it's 48 suggested is number
one this video has an amazing future
shelf life ahead of it
what's Drew saying uh oh you have more
data from Ben's Channel yeah I mean
getting data is not an issue there is
tons I have tons of data on this I want
to share
um not Ben so I want to share uh this
one because hey Heidi's in the group
now the other thing that Eddie was
really concerned about was well what if
I go
and upset my community
what if I upset the people who are here
who are used to my four minute seven
minute 10 minute videos they don't they
don't want a three hour long video if
you look at the comments
I haven't seen a nasty Eddie this suck
stop posting long videos right you're
awesome brother keep up the great work
you surely are channeling your light in
the darkness of others so freaking good
thank you thank you so much bro this
compilation is absolutely amazing thank
you buddy for inspiring right
so the comments the the data is showing
us that it works but the qualitative
data with the comments is also uh really
helping us
now just as a quick comparison the next
video he launched was two days later and
was four four minutes something
so three hours the one we just looked at
the next video was for almost five
minutes
I hate four or five minute videos inside
that leadership uh but let's look at a
quick comparison to see right so so far
this one has more views the shorter one
has more views
even though it came out two days later
the views are actually decent this is a
good video for him right the gray line
is average this is this reviews and he's
at the upper end of his average reviews
which is great the watch time though is
way below his average
and that may or may not catch up
the difference is here
we look at his real time I pulled this I
don't know 30 minutes ago there's no
suggested on this page
browse notifications channels YouTube
search other features so if suggested
here it's less than five percent this is
a big problem so this these kinds of
videos put you on the the rat wheel is
that a thing hamster wheel the hamster
wheel put you on a hamster wheel
thinking Rat Race and hamster wheel
combined becomes rat wheel this video
puts you on the rat wheel where you
basically have to keep making video
video video video video video
just to get the short-term views but
there's no long-term sustainability on
most of these because you can't rely on
browse notifications is going to go away
because notifications uh you know it's
only at the very very beginning of a
video and with no suggested it's going
to go down and that says I'm on the rat
wheel
kind of new term uh and also without you
know diving deep and sharing all revenue
numbers for Eddie this video is getting
less than half of the CPM so even though
it has more views right now short term
out of the gate it looks better this
video is is going to be a lot harder for
him to get views get subscribers and is
making less than half of the CPM on the
video compared to that three hour one
that he just did cool let me just share
a couple examples and we'll from from my
top 10 channel so
this is one we did here
now this is a newer thing right this is
an old video this is 500 days old
so the views this is an hour long video
where normally I'd be making you know 15
to 20 minute videos so it's hour 20
massively underperformed on the views
but now it's picking up on The View so
now it's in the average of our views
the watch time was you know average but
now you know it's popping a lot harder
this one same thing 400 Days old like
this is a relatively new thing where
YouTube is really showcasing promoting
longer videos
I wouldn't have recommended the strategy
back here
400 days ago
but past six months heck yeah
so views massively underperformed and
then boom took off
watch hours you can't even see the
average line it's you know it's tiny
there this one took off
and if you just look at the traffic
sources you can see why right the blue
line is suggested
um the green line is browsed so as you
get more suggested it'll be recommended
and browse more too you'll see these
often browse can Trail suggested but
it's 69 coming from suggested
so going along makes that huge huge huge
difference
Channel analytics these are the basics I
had to cover up the basics because this
is something everybody looks at but
views watch times and Subs gain I don't
know a single YouTuber who doesn't look
at this on their Channel how many views
did I get last month how much watch time
did I get how many Subs did I get it's
not super informative because a lot of
times they're all connected
so if a video blows up for you it's
going to have lots of views it's going
to lead to lots of watch time and you're
going to get a lot of Subs from it so
it's not very very insightful but it's
good it's good just to have a high level
overview
um and if you if you have goals that
you're working towards most people's big
goals are tied to one of these three
metrics usually views are Subs
um because you want to get that that
plaque you want to get that million
subscriber plaque or the 100 000
subscriber plaque or it makes you feel
good to say you have 10 000 subscribers
on your channel but it doesn't really
help us that much in terms of making
strategic decisions this is more just
many metrics that people go after and
it's just a good General Benchmark
Revenue though is important so
for some of you Revenue might be a main
driver where you're trying to really
make a lot of money from the YouTube
channel and you want that to be the
thing that um
pays for everything and for some of you
you have a business that's attached to
it and you don't really care how much
revenue the channel makes you're trying
to drive app downloads or you're trying
to drive coaching sales you're trying to
drive book sales or your program sales
or whatever it is that you're trying to
sell so depending on where you're at
with Revenue this might be really
important or might not be but every
month I definitely recommend going in
and checking your Revenue tab
and what it'll show you is
quite often when you release a video so
look at this as an example when they
release a video the revenue spikes right
so video comes out Revenue pops each
time so I put the thing here is hey
maybe we should release more videos if
your goal is to make more money off the
channel we should be releasing more than
whatever this is five videos in a month
the other really important thing to look
at here is top earning videos
so on their top earning videos it'll
show you recently right so this is past
20 days and you can I usually go 90 but
you can do it with 28. you see what's
popping right now on the channel not the
videos that did well three years ago if
you've been around that long but what's
happening right now and what what you'll
almost always find is there are it's not
even not the 80 20 rule it's like the 98
2 rule like two two percent of your
videos end up driving 98 of the revenue
it's a pretty giant number in comparison
so even looking at this these guys you
know they've they made 4 500 bucks in
the past 28 days their top video looks
like that's 400
is that 400 no 600 600 500 400 400 300
and then it's going to be a big drop off
so you'll find that there are some
videos that just pay you super well
because they have a really high uh CPM
so advertisers care about this topic
and others they won't
and so that could guide content decision
so if revenue from advertisements are
something that really are important to
you we're looking at making longer
videos you know 10 minutes plus but
an hour two hours three hours if you
want
um and then really paying attention to
which videos are actually bringing money
in for you because inside every Niche
they're going to be these super specific
videos that just pop off really well for
you and so you look can I make a round
two of it so if monetization is really
really important to you then looking at
your top videos that earn money
and trying to make that into either a
weekly series or some 5 7 10 20 part
series for the channel if you have more
content to share on it one because it
pays well and two because you can show
up as suggested against those videos so
when somebody's done the first Harvard
video from Pablo and then they see that
there's more they're likely to click on
those ones as well so the first one's
making the money the second one's gonna
third the third the fourth the fifth the
sixth Etc are gonna keep making him
money much more typically than your
average video
so if you're ignoring the revenue tab
there's so much you can dive into on
YouTube analytics I don't want to
overwhelm you and stress you out
but I'm here trying to give you the most
important ones to pay attention to that
I would do if I were you on a monthly
basis so
Revenue paying attention to does your
Revenue go up every time you post a
video or is it more flat so this is a
candidate definitely for making more
content like these guys badly need to
make more content
um and then also your top videos based
off Revenue can you make into a series
foreign
traffic sources I obsess over traffic
sources you should start to obsess over
traffic sources where we want to be is
suggested being our number one traffic
Source the way to blow up a YouTube
channel is off of suggested use
which means you're showing up after
other people's videos
so the first game is ranking against
your own videos and we we did a
presentation on this a month ago showed
you the main ways on how to get
suggested it's it's critically important
because when you start showing up first
against your own videos and then against
other people's videos that's when
YouTube algorithm takes over and you
really start to blow up all your content
where if browse is your number one or
search is your number one it's going to
be a lot harder to really scale so
every month I would definitely pay
attention to on a channel level where
are my traffic sources what are they
looking at and is it improving
so it's it suggested fifth on your list
this month and is it you know fourth on
the list next month third on the list
are we moving in the right direction
because there's only so many views that
come from search and there's only so
many views that come from browse
or the most of the views the biggest
number of views that you'll be able to
get is from suggested so step number one
is showing up against your own channel
and
whenever uh I'm working with somebody
and I see that suggestion becomes number
one as a traffic Source I get really
excited for them but I'm not seeing a
huge increase yet it doesn't matter it's
coming because suggested is number one
because before you can show up against
other people's channels you have to show
up against your own
so a quick hack is to go to Google or
YouTube Incognito load up your channel
play a video and see how many of your
own show up down the side
but this is the the Deep work to show
you hey here's how many views I'm
actually getting from suggested
so every month I would start to really
pay attention you guys can all go look
at your channels now look at past 28
days and then look at where you were the
month before in the month before and are
we heading in the right direction
because this is the ultimate game to
really blow up our YouTube channels
and the last one I look at on a channel
level is frequency so how often are we
posting
uh I mean my channel we're posting every
single day
but when I'm looking at diving into
somebody else's Channel that's what I'm
paying attention to how often are we
posting content there's only so much you
can glean from the data if we haven't
posted a video in 11 months right so for
for most people the frequency needs to
be going up so
this is my general recommendation to
people so if you're not posting very
frequently at all get to once a week so
step number one is how do we get once a
week some content on the channel
and and that should be the goal whether
it's talking to the team or talking to
the owners or whoever like hey we need
to create our goal for June needs to be
to get a video week to come out on the
channel
because then that makes all this other
stuff more relevant more practical more
applicable
uh if you're already out once a week you
go three times a week
if you're ready three times a week you
go we you go daily seven times a week
Beyond this I don't I don't recommend
adding more content I'd recommend really
diving into which videos are performing
well for you
uh but it most people aren't here some
people have a goal to get here which is
great don't stress out once a week is
really just getting you in the game
so looking at this channel as an example
again where you see this little button
here that's that's when they uploaded a
video so you see everything spikes when
they upload a video so this is a channel
that is just crying for new content if
this was a flat if you look at my
channel it's it's
My Views don't really explode when I put
out a new video
because I'm doing it so frequently but
Their audience here is really crying for
new content
and so you have to you know that would
be my number one suggestion for this
channel
and for any of you who haven't posted in
a while
I get that it can be hard and maybe
discouraging or maybe feel like you
don't have the right strategy or know
what to do
um
part of it is just getting it in your
system to get out of video once a week
every week
figure out put in your calendar put in
your schedule whether it's you doing it
whether you're you're working with an
Editor to help you
for any of this analytics stuff to be
meaningful to you you have to be at
least making one video a week at least I
really want you at three
I would secretly really want you at
seven but
let's get the let's get the one a week
let's get the one a week going so those
are some channel uh level Analytics
series analytics this is where when you
have some kind of consistent content you
can start to look at what kinds of
videos are performing well versus not so
series examples could be you're going to
do a talking head video you're going to
do a coaching video you're going to do a
demonstration video you're going to do a
one-on-one with a client video you're
going to do a reaction video you're
going to do a how-to video You're Gonna
Do a video from uh the stage you're
gonna do a big Zoom call video like
you're playing with different ideas
so that you can start to see which ones
are working out if you're up if you're
starting to work towards a Content
calendar and you're moving from the once
a week to three to seven don't do the
same kind of video on repeat
don't just stick to one format start to
play with different types different
content styles that that feel right for
you
um for example I don't do reaction
videos
um I find a lot of the reaction videos
are are kind of negative it's like I
can't believe he just said that oh my
God what an idiot like I don't like
putting that energy out so I don't I
don't I don't like reaction videos
there's no reaction videos the only
reaction video I've ever done is me
reacting to my first video and I watched
it back and was mostly embarrassed and
laughing at myself for how bad it was
um but for some of you maybe that's
maybe that is what would work super well
um so it's got to be it's got to feel
right it's got to be authentic but if
you're if you're getting to multiple
times a week make sure that you're
having different kinds of Series so you
can start
um seeing the data and seeing what's
working what's not
this is kind of a messy graph so I'm
going to explain it this is what I go
through with my team
every month
um and this is this is some old data but
I pulled it up just to show you as an
example
this we use for every series on the
channel so I just pulled three out for
you guys to look at this is a top 10
Series this is my top 50 Series and this
is the espresso which is a morning
Series so this is us doing you know top
10 at Oprah Winfrey top 50 at Oprah
Winfrey espresso is more me talking so
be uh a clip and then I'm talking about
it and then this goes on so we have each
color is a different channel so these
are just two channels and then there's a
green Channel and then red and orange
and this is some giant sheet that I
didn't want to overwhelm you guys with
but what this basically looks at and and
um I've been on my team he he pulls this
together for me once a month and we have
a call once a month to go over it is
we're looking at watch time
for the past month of videos and then
how many subscribers we gain per video
so what these two numbers mean is
if we were making our data uh what month
is it now we're in May okay so for June
when we have our meeting this number is
going to reflect how well how many watch
hours did we get
per video on average in this series for
two months back so the videos that
launched in April
one month of data being collected
and then
we talk about it in June
the reason why we do it like that is uh
a channel that like mine has been around
for so long
a lot of the data a top 10 video from
2016 isn't relevant anymore to what's
happening right now
so I care about the new videos that are
coming up and how well they've done in
their first four to six weeks
so
the April videos
are contained so there might be let's
say there's 10 April videos in the top
10 Series so those 10 videos that
launched in April and if you guys have
questions pop it in the chat because
this this part might be a little
confusing so I'm happy to answer and go
deeper on it but if we release 10 top 10
videos in April
in June we then go back and look at all
the data
and say okay our top 10 videos got us on
average
389 000 watch hours and each video got
us on average 79 new subscribers between
launch date and June
between April and June now these will go
on to continue to do super well but
we're tracking what happened in the
first four to six weeks of each video
uh so what this helps us do is start to
analyze okay which series do we keep
going with and which series do we cut
so you know we uh we we did all these
top tens and I wanted to show this this
data is probably
2017 2016 data
um but we've kept this going you know if
I look to show you my recent ones should
that the newer stuff
this is where we did our first top 50 to
say Hey what if we launch a new series
top 50.
let's just go super long on a video
so you can see our top tens we're doing
122 000 watch hours and 16 subscribers
per video in that month we did a top 50
and look at the jump it went from it
went to 600 000 watch hours and 61
subscribers per video
the next month did Super well the next
month didn't do so well we lost
subscribers and only 120 000 watch hours
so we're constantly comparing these
numbers and you can look at it across
Series so if we look at it this month
here
you can see okay so the top 10 got got
six figures watch time 17 subscribers
top 50 crushed it on both and the
espresso got 51 000 about half the watch
hours of this but double the subscribers
and so we're constantly playing with the
series to see which ones are doing well
then inside each one you can dive in to
see well which which video did well for
us inside here
you know so if these are 10 videos which
of them did Super well and which ones
didn't to give us more information but
this for you could be you know coaching
Series this could be again all the
different options direct the camera
reaction
Etc and you start to pay attention to
how many watch hours did I get from
these videos and how many subscribers
did I gain from these videos if you
wanted to add the third column of
Revenue you could too revenue is
typically more topic driven though
then series driven
um but if that's really really important
to you we don't track Revenue as a as
the main metric for our YouTube videos
um we care mostly about growth so
Drew's got his hand up what where what
do you got Drew so I'm just trying to
make sure I understand so each row
represents a single month
of that series having been released yes
yes yeah so this would be June July
August September you know October and so
on
so when collecting that data so I'm
assuming this is like on one
page and then on another page you have
each individual video the total
cumulative and then that number just
simply reflects the sum of all of the
videos that were released that month
yeah so if again if this was June it'd
be the sum of all the videos
from April that were released
and then divided by how many videos are
released so this is an average this is
per video oh oh okay okay yeah because
we'll do
you know we'll end up doing 22 top tens
in a month but only one top 50 as an
example
so to add them all up it doesn't make
sense you have to then give me on a per
video basis I don't think you have to go
this deep even just I I'm obsessed with
this stuff so I've shown this to other
big YouTubers like nobody tracks it as
detailed as you guys do
um so you don't have to go to this level
I'm just showing you the idea is I want
you to start thinking about on a series
level so we looked at Channel which is
great but that's
to Ashley's question about how do we
make strategic decisions that's hard
when you're just looking at total views
and total revenue
um total subscribers Etc once you get to
a series by series level it starts to
educate us to say hey these ones are
doing better than others so if I look at
this line and just a one-off month what
usually do it for at least three months
to see
a one-off month isn't enough
typically so but this month like the top
50 looks like a a runaway winner and the
next month it's also looking doing
really well on the watch hours not as
well on the subscribers compared and
then next month whatever we did here
sucked right we lost 21 subscribers so I
don't know who we profiled or what that
video was now again all these videos
will still end up winning long term
this is first four to six weeks
and why four to six weeks is because
that's usually how long it takes for
suggested to start to kick in
you might have a crazy runaway winner
that suggests it starts to pop you know
within the first week but for the most
part for most videos
you give that four to six week window
usually after 30 day Mark you start to
see suggested views go up if the video
is going to do well if you still don't
see any suggested views after 30 or 60
days that video is probably dead
um so it could be worth doing a redo on
the thumbnail title or just the video
you know itself wasn't very good
so this is how every month every month
since 2015 uh I've met with my guy Ivan
and we go over this and we make
decisions afterwards from this and this
sheet this is only three columns this
sheet is maybe 20 columns long for all
of our series
and we'll just dive into each one and
say okay okay this one this one's not
looking so good what do we need to do to
fix it
and the goal is always to try to pull
out the always have one test series that
we're trying to beat
the rest of our content to make it back
in
so if you're if you're making three
videos a week as an example you have
your two that you know are consistent
winners and then you have your one
that's a test so maybe you're trying a
book review or maybe you're trying a
role player maybe you're trying uh a
coaching call you're trying something
for four weeks to just to see how well
are we doing and you're always trying to
beat the winner
video analytics is on a on an individual
video level how well are we doing what
data do I look at what are the important
things to pay attention to
uh so The Impressions and click-through
rate are super super super super super
important
you can get lost in data on individual
videos but this is one of the most
important things to pay attention to so
if you go to your channel you click on
analytics on the side
and then you look at uh the Impressions
you get on the videos I usually like
going 90 days again so it's what's most
relevant right now what's popping
and then we're looking at our
click-through rate that's what this
means here impression click-through rate
and people when they ask me what's a
good click-through rate
it's a it's a logical question asked but
it's not a great question
because
click-through rate is relative
so
here's what happens if you have a really
high click-through rate on your video
and the video is doing well it's got
good retention on your video YouTube's
going to recommend it to more people who
don't know who we are
which is great that's a that's a great
thing to have happen but the more
YouTube recommends our videos to people
who don't know us
our click-through rate is going to drop
because it's more and more and more of a
colder audience
so if your video comes out if if Ash is
finally launches a new video to having
solution you know it's going to be great
we're all going to cheer and celebrate
so when that that video comes out
chances are you know the people who
these 113 000 subscribers who follow
tapping solution her channel uh are
probably gonna really like the video
they're like oh my God new videos is
great
and if that video starts doing well it's
now going to reach out to more and more
people who have never heard of the
typing solution who don't even know
what's happening is and that's the
ultimate goal because our goal is not
just to talk to people who already know
who we are our goal is to talk to people
who have no idea who we are
and that's the power of YouTube but as
we start branching out if if Ashley is
making a video on tapping if it's going
to tapping people they're going to have
a high click-through rate right they
know what it is they like it if it's
going to people have no idea who what's
happening is the click through rate is
going to drop
so a low click-through rate is not
necessarily a bad thing if it's reaching
a broad audience
so a good click-through rate is relative
to how many Impressions you're getting
on the video
it's relative to how your other videos
are doing
so
for example if I see a video that has
um a 12 a 12 click-through rate
that's actually not grid that's not good
because it means YouTube is not
recommending your video to enough new
people
you're only talking to your current
audience that means there's probably
something wrong with the video itself
you did a great job on your thumbnail
and title to get people to click but the
video itself kind of sucks
nobody's actually watching it so YouTube
doesn't want to recommend it to more
people
so this is why this graph is so
important whenever I'm looking at doing
split testing on my channel and or
looking at other people's channels as
well
if you sort by how many Impressions you
have so these are all different videos
with different Impressions then you can
look at the relative
click-through rate
so the channel average for those 90 days
was four percent
and then these are the ones that I want
to fix like two percent 2.1 2.6
uh 2.8 so anything in the twos on here
now if my number one video was two
percent I'm not worried about that
but if this video has 160 000
Impressions look at these two videos 160
000 I'm sorry 161 million
I can't read 161 million impressions on
this video
156 million impressions on the pretty
close right almost the same what's five
million impressions they're pretty close
here at the top
five percent click-through rate two
percent click-through rate
so this video got double the views more
than double the views of this video off
the same number of impressions
so this thumbnail has to be fixed this
thumbnail title combination has to be
fixed
and so that's what you do you keep
looking in different impression bands
and you start to see
if I'm looking at you know the if I look
in the 40 000 here so 42 to 48 the best
one here is 3.3 percent
these ones are underperforming so I want
to go in and fix all of these ones
why it's so important is even just
looking at these two as an example
YouTube is recommending the videos to
people
it's giving us impressions
people aren't clicking
this is the problem with how we're
presenting our video
YouTube thinks our video is good that's
why we're getting the impressions
but people aren't clicking so our cover
sucks
right and this isn't a subjective like I
work so hard on that thumbnail how could
people not like it okay well they don't
like it you know fix it
it's it's not being I like making data
driven decisions so even though I pour
there's been thumbnails that I just pour
my heart and soul into or titles that I
just feel are just epic and amazing I'm
so proud of myself and then you know 2.1
click through okay perfect that one
sucked let's go next and keep testing
keep trying but this gives you Direction
on a per video level where to go and
start making changes and updates and
this is why YouTube is so powerful is
that you can go back and fix this stuff
where Facebook Instagram Twitter
whatever you're not going back and
updating this video might be eight years
old I could still go back and update
Ramsay media has got his hand up you got
something quick
hey Evan can you just provide a little
more context for us about earlier you
said if your number one video is in the
high twos you're not worried about it
and I and I and given what you're saying
about the other stuff I'm like but why
like like why wouldn't you still want to
raise that click-through rate
I'm not worried about it because it's
reaching a big wide audience so if
you're doing your hypnosis videos and
you're talking to hypnosis people
they're gonna they're gonna love it
but if you're reaching
say your video shows up against my
audience
a bunch of entrepreneurs
most people are probably familiar with
the term hypnosis but maybe haven't
watched a video or don't know how it
works so if you're if you're branching
out like the fact that these numbers are
close means that this one has to be
fixed but if this one often the number
one video might have
you know way higher so in this world
maybe it has a billion Impressions and
compared to 161. it doesn't mean that
you can't go back and continue to try to
improve it I keep working on my top
videos as well to try to make them
better
but it just means that it's not a bad
number I I would expect the top video on
your channel to have the lowest
click-through rate
it's very typical
so this one just massively over
performed here at the five percent it's
very rare to have I gotta look at what
this video is because it's very rare to
have your number one video be better
than your channel average
this would be if you if we remove this
first one this is what this would be
what I would expect 2.1 2.6 3.5 3.7 3.54
and then we start getting the higher
numbers as we start to go down if you
have a giant Gap
between number one and number two or
number one two three four five like if
you look at your own data and pull it up
don't freak out
if if your number one video is two
percent
it means it's reaching a new audience so
it's good
it doesn't mean that you still can't
improve it but it doesn't mean that it's
a bad click-through rate oh my God why
does this one suck so much
the next thing that we look at is
audience retention at one minute
so on a per video basis this is another
thing that I'm obsessed over so every
video we've gone through this I've
shared some examples we've done Channel
breakdowns but if you're looking at how
to fix your individual videos It's a
combination of
the click-through rate which is title
and thumbnail and then also the
retention how much are people actually
sticking so if you had a 12
click-through rate video
uh I'm expecting this curve to look
really bad the one minute retention is
probably going to be really poor you
didn't keep people
so what I'm obsessed with was trying to
hit the 70 at one minute that's that's
virtually impossible to do consistently
but it's a high high Mark so you want to
be a good starting point is 50 at one
minute and then working our way up 60 is
a really good number 70 is insane gold
standard try to hit that and when you're
looking at your curve this basically
just shows where people are falling off
so you know this first whatever we this
is a 13 minute video so this part sucks
and then it goes up so especially when
you see it go up like that wow this part
really sucks we should cut that you know
for future videos don't don't do that
stuff again and then it's okay and then
there's this you know slow curve this is
what it we want it to look like these
Peaks here this is what we cut for
Instagram and Twitter is the highest
engagement moment so we're cutting that
out free social content and this is what
I'm still doing now guys I mean I'm
helping Brendan burchard launch three
um YouTube channels around his growth
day product so we joint ventured on them
and every week my team is pulling
together a list of clips
based off of this so when the curve goes
up Brendan here's the clips for social
media for this week and then his team
Cuts them together you know from here to
here so for this video I'd probably go
you know this is a short little
Instagram reel here and then from here
to here is an Instagram video
or Tick Tock video
right and so the data just shows us what
people are liking
so it one it tells us how to fix our
videos right this really sucks don't do
that again the ending sucks as well look
how many people we lost at the end don't
do that again
flat lines are great slow curves are
good and any increases we're cutting for
social and also looking what happened
did I say something great
um did a CAT walk in the background you
know like what happened that made people
really want to watch this part and then
try to do more of that
uh so on a per video basis click-through
rate and then one minute audit retention
we really really pay a lot of attention
to if you want to see this full video as
well as trained live with me twice a
month to blow up your brand join the
brand Linux training program there's a
link to join right there next to me
continue to believe I'll see you there